I don't wear nautical it's not even
Friday Honda hahahahahahaha what have
you done to me oh no oh no way hey
what's all the racket oh I did he
adorable oh I've got one for you too
ahoy matey
what come on smile smell for the camera
it makes me feel weak Nicolaitans
goodbye because I'm more come back here
I'm dead down there come on
everyone has tickle spot the temple cap
we're making plans for their newest
addition your new
but this baby has a good plan
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy Polly oh no
that's exactly the problem have you
learned anything
ABC me no what have you learned about
puppies very properly no Jimbo puppies
are evil Stacey be better though I can't
read what could say look yeah
oh it's like they're having a little
meeting last dessert humiliating you're
gonna fight babies John I know how
important this mission is with the
company haha poop duty I've got a deal
with the K ID yeah are you I'm on a
mission it's not enough love to go
around my job is to find out why he'll
give me a double espresso and see if it
someplace around here with decent sushi
I kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now
[Applause]
oh it wouldn't look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice
the final succeed with this mission I
will live here forever with you okay I
will help you but just to get rid of you
deal you come to Rio know you're
watching you too okay shoot you on that
how we can ask the guard I've never been
so humiliated in my life better bring
nothing I don't we're not anything I'll
have it done to me what's all the racket
I did he adorable
oh I've got one for you too what bummer
dream work the boss baby put that cookie
down
cookies offer closer
[Applause]
you